last time on google translate Dragon
Ball Z cell took it one step too far and
a Gohan clock went off what do we have
in store next for our heroes find out
now
you cat how no I do not know I
super-elite know that's it history on
this planet
do I hear Kakarot it just complete oh
this is not good
Islip recover not from the last attack
eliminate this stinking planet I'll just
use my garlic cannon and blow everything
Kakarot if you can dodge attacks but I
miss you even going on this entire earth
snow
hahahaha well done dead tree planet
Kakarot great one now I'm not ready oh
man I don't have a choice it's now or
never
triple Kyle prefecture attack right now
come there they are
Marquita
Oh
let's see what you got Kakarot garlic
and Lika this meant I do
goodbye Evo jelly donuts could I happen
it can't be as strong as he beat the
garlic cannon
kiyo freezer attack time
what do you want to see next from our
heroes leave a suggestion down below for
what you want to see thank you for
watching and I will see you on the next
exciting episode of Google Translate
Dragon Ball Z